Miracle on the Hudson that was kind of a
good omen in a bad period and it
happened a 100 seconds after takeoff we
lost thrust in both engines it was a
life-changing event for everyone on the
airplane the NTSB investigation which is
a big part of the story that people
don't know until I read the script I
didn't know the investigative board was
trying to hate the picture that he had
done the wrong thing they were kind of
railroading him into this fault and that
wasn't the case at all there's something
about the near miss like that it makes
you appreciate life as you have it
cactus 1549 runway board clear for
takeoff
- is 1523 Clifford
I never get over how beautiful it is up
here life's easier in the air
Mayday Mayday Mayday this detective 1549
lost trust on both engines we are
turning back towards the Guardia I have
an emergency
we've lost both engines returning
immediately today we begin with our
investigation on the crash of US Airways
flight 1549 1549 if we can get a few you
want to try to land runway once right
we're running but we may end up at the
hustle this was not a crash
this was dual engine loss at a lower
altitude than any jet in history with
155 souls on board cactus 1549 its enemy
left traffic for only 3-1 on it okay
what do you need to land no one has ever
trained for an incident like that 1549
runway force available I don't think we
can make any runway what about over to
our right off your right side is
Teterboro Airport look I'm sorry if
you're frustrated but our job is to
investigate how a plane ended up in the
Hudson River we're fine didn't get this
right endangered the lives of all those
passengers okay you're scaring me now
Sully you can lam runway one Teterboro
we can make it okay which runway would
you like a Teterboro
I've delivered a million passengers over
40 years but in the end I'm gonna be
judged on 208 seconds we're gonna end up
in the Hudson I'm sorry say again cactus
this is the captain
brace for impact
no one warned us no one said you were
going to lose both engines at a lower
altitude than any jet in history this